welcome everybody today shri podcasts
live today we are here with a very
special guest we have got no sponsors no
[ __ ] going on we have got Chris and
Dylan here you guys may have heard of
these guys because they've been making a
splash on the scene lately
getting out a lot seen you guys all over
the place one list one life can you guys
fill me in a little bit of the backstory
of who you guys are and what's going on
sure yeah so Dylan and I have been
friends since fourth grade I just beyond
that we were never really like the super
fantastic close friends in fourth grade
you know just friends in the elementary
school and then in fifth grade I got hit
with the diagnosis of chronic myeloid
leukemia and Dylan was literally in the
hospital with me every single day it was
a obviously as a young kid it was a
crazy battle but having someone there we
played video games like every day on the
PlayStation 2 that's literally all I did
you know take my mind off of stuff and
it was it was a big deal to go
throughout the time as a kid but you
know luckily I got through it modern
medicine and all that and I've just been
taking these what's called experimental
chemo it's called like Gleevec spry cell
clue cig and I've been taking that for a
few years now and recently unfortunately
in October of 2017 I was doing just a
normal routine blood check and I got a
call when I was at my college letting me
know that they found something that is
really not good and that I would need to
go back for more tests and about three
days of back and forth of them telling
me oh it's a good mutation oh it's a bad
mutation then finally they were like
this is a terrible mutation this is
really oh my maybe bad never seen this
mutation before this is a first so they
weren't sure for the first few days like
they're like this could be good like it
is stronger now and it won't you know
attack the body or whatever or like it
is and it's just resilient to medication
so once I was given that news it really
hit me pretty hard obviously how long
ago was that that was just in October of
last year so it's just been a few months
so five months into my year you're left
pretty much to enjoy life I've been
doing a crazy crazy job of it thanks to
Dylan when I was when I first got told
he was the first person I called even
before my mom and he cuz he was in the
hospital my parents have work and you
know they had to do stuff but still I
mean it was he was a really big part of
it and he told me write down 50 items
that were gonna do like no playing
around this isn't just you know being
trying to be a nice guy like he's like
write down 50 items and we're doing them
and it just it started from there just
small things like you know just what it
is on normal people's I would say bucket
lists like go to space and stuff like
that and then I was just like crazy
stuff like meeting you guys and it's
just like this should never happen just
like all right Ian - h3h like stuff like
that and because like you guys are the
people who when I'm going through
terrible stuff like I can just put on a
video and forget that I'm dying of
cancer content can make wit like can
make me whatever the bad stuff I'm going
through chemo problems whatever I can
just put some memes on and you know just
watch it and it's it's it takes me away
from the crappy situation of like
stomach pains whatever it is it's just
like alright I get to focus on something
funny and so thanks like having you guys
on the bucket list is really like
instead of I would say normal
celebrities you guys are like my my
celebrities so it's really cool to
actually get to be as what we do cuz
we're kind of separated we don't really
interact with our audience that much so
like hearing that it's crazy it's so
crazy man
I mean I'm honored said that that we got
the opportunity to sit down with you
thank you no I want people to know that
they're well there's still a chance for
you to recover from yes of course it is
bone-marrow donations right now the only
thing that can save me is a bone marrow
donation and most people just say oh
can't your parents do it or can't a
sibling unfortunately I had a sibling
she committed suicide in 2014 and she
was only a
about a six match and they can go all
the way up to a ten out of ten so my own
sister she wasn't enough no yeah well my
mom is only a three out of six and yeah
most it's pretty much a numbers game the
more people that sign up to be a
registered donor what are the chances do
you know it's only 30% that you're gonna
find a family member it is a match so I
know that's probably not the exact
numbers you were looking for but that's
because it just depends on races it's
purely general so African Americans and
oriental people they have a lot harder
time because you know there's North
Korea South Korea Japan all those things
are genetically so racial purity yeah
yeah I was when they take out my bone
marrow and they say that oh okay he's
Portuguese Puerto Rican and blah blah
blah that's a tough one so yeah and it's
it's a hard thing and it even goes as
far as like I remember you got some
weird virus oh yeah and it's viruses too
like they have to have every single
virus like it's your bone marrow has to
accept someone else's that is gonna be
making good white glow the white blood
cells don't match it's literally gonna
be civil so here's what I want to do
today I've been following you guys story
there's somebody out there with the bone
marrow to save your life
even if you don't match him you can save
somebody else's life yeah and the
process I thought it was super scary and
crazy but having followed you guys story
it's it's very simple it's like a and
what do you call it outpatient it just
takes like an hour you show up they pop
a needle in your hip you go that's if
you're actually mad process you get on
the list is to get on the registry you
just swab your mouth and it's a free you
go online yep I'm gonna talk about that
later I'm gonna tell you guys how to do
that later in the show
but I want to say if anybody at home is
watching now one it said advise you guys
a little bit in case of saving a life
for basically nothing wasn't enough
incentive if anybody matches you and
donates I'm gonna give him $5,000 so if
anybody's out there who wants to help
this dude out you can save his life and
I'm gonna pay you $5,000 thank you and
I'm gonna give you a hill this is a
priceless offer my
it's gonna be weird when some like
Chinese dude matches with you and then
we have to send them to Ethan you the
hand ease option I'll send you the check
so I'm gonna tell you guys Walt here let
me bring Dan throw it up on the screen
we'll talk more about it later
before we get today we'll talk more
about it later but there is a lot of
misconception about the process and I
was under the wrong impression as well I
thought you have to like immediately do
the donation but that's completely yeah
yeah it's basically two steps you sign
up to the registry and then if you match
with someone then you're saving life
yeah that part's a little harder but you
know you're saving in life I've done
bone marrow biopsies before I'd say 2015
they used to have to take to check on my
cancer levels like in depth they used to
have to take a bone marrow say would
sedate me do all the whole process and
it was literally a pain and but now
luckily they have just a genetics test
which they just take like seven files of
blood and then they'll figure it out
that way but yeah I had to do literally
have probably done six not eight of them
one of the of the old school which is
just they sedate you and that's what
they would do if you are a match and
it's just what you sedate you you're
just on your belly and they get bone
marrow from your hip it literally just
feels like you got like charley horse
trot above the butt cheek for you've
done it eight times yeah yeah ever since
2009 ever they had me do it
every there are three times every year
and then down to two times every year
and that was the most I got him space
now six months so you can basically just
go in for a day we'll explain it more
but I'm not the only one that's on your
list there was someone else on your list
that happens to be here now so we're
gonna bring him in yeah you're the who
yeah oh no no it's Philip DeFranco
Billy Dee I noticed that Billy was on
your list here sit here oh that's so
that's the ghost of a live this is the
was on your list and we and Philip
wanted to come and meet you guys already
anyway thank you so what happened so
fortunately that we got I just sent an
email to your producer like an hour ago
yeah yeah well we were we were talking
about uh I was like hey I know these
guys are reaching out let's let's set
something up and and she said yeah we're
doing it and Ethan hit me up and I was
like yeah let's completely just just
kind of hit him from the side I thought
you were gonna make a joke about like so
anyway obviously thank you I just wanted
to continue the conversation we're
having you so this you dropped out of
college when you found out that you have
cancer that the story of you guys's
friendship really it's really touching
about everything you guys have been
through I mean how was it deciding that
you were gonna drop out of college and
how did your family feel about yeah
actually I'll start with how my family
feels I am losing my job and getting
kicked out in about two weeks yeah I
don't know if my mom is actually gonna
enforce that I think it's more like
kicking you out my parents I think it's
a threat right it's like go back to
college or we're gonna kick you out I'm
curious to see if it actually happens
but hey I like the very soft language
I'm curious what happens and it happens
you know it's like it's not ideal but he
won't be on that's the fastest way to
test out a friendship
sleep sleep next to each other
actually we we almost got we had a share
of bed almost tonight car Hotel kind of
messed up we fixed it so we just hang
out way too much it was literally used
to be like I would hang it out of his
house for like Monday through Friday and
then he would go to hang out at my house
for like it would just be weeks just
trading off just at each others house so
we're pretty used to each other's
shenanigans - so your parents don't
really understand what you're doing or
well you guys are well I my parents they
kind of went through the whole process
of like living from a car and then you
know my mom went to college now she's a
nurse and so she sees the opportunity of
getting that degree right and obviously
she understands that I've been friends
with Chris for a long time and that she
understands that he's dying but it's
it's scary for it's hard to say even
with all those facts it's really a tough
choice to make yeah
and actually she just paid for more
classes so I'm technically supposed to
start class like next week but I told
her I'm not going to do that because
yeah I mean it basically just came down
to you know if he does pass that I can't
sit in a lecture hall listening to the
Linguistics of Norway or whatever I was
doing well I know that he's sitting in
the hospital you know and at this point
because that commitment we made together
like on March 1st we broke a world
record and together the two of us we
have we are the people that have made
the most amount of people sign up for a
bone marrow registry in one day and it's
like if I didn't make that decision you
know then our effort would have been
posting on Facebook you sign up as a
marrow donor and then if he died you
know it almost would have been like not
necessarily my fault but I wouldn't have
put in my effort and now we're feeling
like okay we may be really I mean like
it's it's just up to someone else which
is the unfortunate part about this
leukemia is it's not like I can just
walk into a hospital just be like carry
me please I'll take one care like now
it's like finally good so I have to wait
for someone so really like we've tried
all we can right now and just hopefully
keep raising the awareness message
because it's not just me there's
hundreds if not thousands yeah so I mean
there's like the perspective of you know
not wanting to lose him right in
and just kind of letting that happen but
also we've had to buy a lot of hard
drives recently because there's so much
footage of experiencing life together
you know for terrible and and then it's
just become luckily we may I made that
decision you know we made the decision
because now we're inspiring people we
people are watching this entire story
and and we have people who care about us
and we care about them and you know at
first yeah it was definitely just I
don't want to sit here knowing that he's
dying but then it very quickly turned
into holy crap like we're doing
something that is actually changing
people's lives
well I think there's plenty of people
watching who'd be like yeah I would
totally put my life on hold just try to
save my friend's life like everybody
likes to stay dream and fantasize about
doing that but actually I think it is a
whole different thing so right because
even what you're saying I mean there
there are real stakes and the fact that
you're you're willing to do that to to
get the experiences that you're getting
now like that's I wouldn't I'm very not
about the romantic yeah I love that yeah
managerial economics cognitive science
and tech management that's what my
parents don't like is the fact that mom
I'm making a youtube video but you know
like we we say now that we're running
out of adjectives to describe what's
happening because like scrolling through
my contacts list I have Danny DeVito
right next to Brody Burns you got Danny
DeVito on speed dial
yeah I'm just wait we're gonna get like
a really populated discord server one
day and were just gonna leak it
just leaked his phone numbers I know
it's a that's the real game plan did you
guys expect to get this kind of
attention like I'm curious how did you
guys start and when was your first like
breakthrough because now it seems like a
lot of people know who you are but in
the beginning how did you first get
realized I I told Chris because a lot of
it was documenting the story right we
wanted people to see that like hey you
know sure and we're in a situation where
he might be dying but really you can go
live out a bucket list and and even our
bucket list kind of portrays that too
you know sure not a lot of people will
be able to sit in this room but we also
want to help an old lady across the
street you might want to feed homeless
and yeah personable as well is I want to
be famous how are you happy like it's
just there's there's so much stuff to do
in life that is beyond just Oh fun
things here fun things there it's what
will make you feel good about helping
someone else like genuinely helping them
not just like alright here's some 10
cents you know like to a homeless guy
like actually genuinely going out there
and making a contact and doing the the
first date cuz we decided to document it
the first day I had the camera in front
of Chris the little camera that I had
from high school
Chris you need to tell a story
effectively because 10,000 people are
gonna watch this okay
first of all if we ran out of batteries
because it took him so long pronouncing
[ __ ] to get one line out oh my god he
was terrible I'm bad I'm like even
originally in front of the camera it was
just like an intro sappy one like we
were talking we made we download we
maybe pirated an Adobe program and we
just like Adobe software in this house
it was crack trying to come up with a
flyer to describe what we are doing and
we were like mapping out okay we're
gonna walk to our neighbors and say this
and maybe we can get some money to be
able went on doing door-to-door to raise
the awareness
yeah we posted it on Reddit and next
thing you know he called me I think it
was with my girlfriend he's like hey
we're at a quarter million views yeah
just walking at the river in the last
time I checked it like three hours
before it was that like 60,000 and I was
are sweating bullets I was just like I
need to walk I need to like and I check
it again like once I stopped walking I'm
like oh that's like our video yeah and
really everything that's happened so far
is because of that first video pretty
much yeah
uncredible reddit sometimes it's great
sometimes it's the worst
yeah it's coin toss it's a it's a real
coin that sometimes I feel about backers
I think we own the rights to the music I
don't think I mean it was terrible but
its production to us you know it's a
story of who we are and and people
definitely didn't like it there are some
people who are very critical of it but
what did they say I'm curiosity it's the
whole spectrum um there are some
conspiracies that I'm stealing all the
money from Chris yeah that I'm actually
like I'm just some puppet just juice and
all the funds out of me he's just in
there just I love how cynical people
gonna be that they can be like even like
why wouldn't I just stop hey like that's
my biggest thing like eight point eight
why wouldn't I just say I'm trouble
because we had a patreon link in the
description and they're like oh you're
just trying because I mean I understand
it but I really have to carry around my
doctor's note that literally says like
and needs to go to the hospital because
he's gonna die soon I have to carry that
on me because people like no you don't
like you want to see yeah yeah I pull
out the paper and I'm just like read it
like that's my name right there like
it's it's real that's it that's the dark
side of the internet people are always
ready to see the worst possible scenario
yeah even the worst possible scenario is
like like just let it go dude if that's
what you think just [ __ ] move on like
don't make it your life's mission to
like [ __ ] on you guys
was the most recent one it was hardcore
so like he dated my sister oh well you
invited I did like back in the day and
like this before that person commented
they were just like oh I know this may
be weird but I for some reason think
that you dating his sister was the
reason that she killed herself and that
you're just in it for the money and like
I was literally just like damn like this
part that was the one comment and it
didn't like personally offend us but
it's just so like yeah it's just a lot
of those levels of like really like
you're gonna hey you're gonna bring up
my dead sister come over like all that
stuff and it's just like because I'm fat
and dumb don't target Dylan because he
dated my sister just weird you guys
actually are are you still posting
videos to our videos no we're trying we
do of our own content well part of it
too was I because we kind of share an
account and and I had some other
accounts and then also people were
pretending to be us saying me and my
best friend are doing this I don't know
what they gain from that so it was there
was some kind of we did take advantage
of the platform because when you post
something there and then suddenly you're
living out your bucket list it's it's
exciting you know and it's like please
care about us some more but a lot of it
too was yeah they just weren't having it
they didn't see our stuff anymore I
guess yeah they were just they were
upset about the self-promotion side of
it more so than what our content was
they could care less if it was literally
saving a starving out of starving
Africans like no I was saying we were
banned in our videos really for like the
first two or three years of our career
on YouTube
yeah and like once we had like a couple
million subscribers we message one of
the admins were like dude can you please
like after all this time can you just
tell me why at least we're banned and
they go back I wish they they went back
to check the logs and they're like it
was one moderator on our videos who
isn't with us anymore and banned you and
didn't even make a note because they're
supposed to like take archive down
banda channel so he didn't even know and
he wasn't with them he's like this was
just one guy that hated you and banned
your frickin channel from our videos I'm
like that's so messed up cuz it's like
the biggest hub of content sharing on
the Internet and maybe one guy probably
like 15 years away from a million
subscribers maybe will message them then
you have a very dark or not dark but
very nonchalant about your condition
yeah part of a coping mechanism or are
you really just that no at peace with
what's going on in your life there's I
think it's a little bit of both it's
definitely a coping mechanism just when
my sister passed like I've made a lot of
suicide jokes and stuff and it's just
like not about me but like hearse and
it's just like so I deal with things
instead of just crying about it and just
being sad about it like it's not gonna
help anything if you can at least try
and laugh and get over things I mean you
can at least try and become a stronger
person afterwards but I feel like just
demonizing all the bad things is just
like it's not helping anything you're
just making more things like touchy
subjects and the least you can make it a
touchy subject and just make it into
like yeah that happened that's life but
unfortunately what happens in life but
yeah just like with the cancer I mean if
I'm done everyone's dying you know what
I mean like everyone's dying I'm running
to the gates a little bit faster maybe
but like there's nothing that not joking
about it can do to save it it's not like
if I don't make any jokes like my
cancers gonna go away so it's like might
as well try and make some laughs and
stuff because I mean no laughter all the
time I've had people literally like I'm
making cancer jokes in public with some
friends and they're just like hey you
can't do that my blooper mile died of
cancer I'm like I'm dying of cancer
right now I do want to see the paper
paper yeah I want to see the paper after
all this talk about the faith this would
be very it just all right let's let's
come on up this is my warrant sorry my
desk all right guys I actually didn't
know he can write everybody at home here
hopefully it's not like you're like this
just so you know this gonna be cut to
make it look like we didn't believe this
is all how we go from laughs okay so he
carries a diagnosis of chronic myeloid
leukemia his current therapy is not very
beneficial you will need to undergo a
bone marrow transplantation which is at
this time of the best curative treatment
for his leukemia yeah it's nothing crazy
but it's just crazy don't you know be
nice so you have you ever bust that out
on people giving over like so how did
they react because I have handicap
handicap because of some surgeries from
bone marrows I had a I let a residency
nurse do one and she really messed up on
it and I I signed off and everything my
whole cancer experience I have said if I
can donate my time and body to science
and help some other kid from dealing
with this then it's definitely worth it
you know what I mean so I let the
residency nurse do it because better me
than some other really younger kid who's
gonna be really messed up and so she
literally cracked part of my hip bone it
was she really messed up the needle for
this home yeah I was I was on crutches
for like three weeks
that won't
if you were a bone marrow designed for
residency nurse for a practice nurse to
do it and stuff and it is permanently
affected my walk and I have a disabled
placard on my car and so that's fun of
park you know going and parking
someplace and I just get out I've had
literally like this I think was a vet
I'm pretty sure he'll give you [ __ ] for
taking me and some [ __ ] he's got the
handicap bike you've got the cancer now
I have the plates I have the plate oh
you don't even talk to people so ask me
oh you have your handicap I don't even
say I point I mean look at the car don't
ask our first like but yes and well they
probably think you're like in your
grandma's car something I have a bunch
of gun stickers on my car gun gun
stickers like that we don't call 9-1-1
like that was like gun brand's okay but
I mean and he you know he just came out
he's like oh why do you deserve that
parking space blahblah fought for my
country and I don't even have it blah
blah blah like and I was living like I
know you fought for your country but I'm
currently fighting cancer and he's just
like oh I'm so sorry
and like I hate being like that but as
soon as people trigger me on that I turn
from not nice to a dick and I was just
like he's like oh I'm so sorry about it
you know I didn't you know I didn't know
I'm like yeah you shouldnt have been
[ __ ] barking up the wrong tree you
had no clue and you just started jumping
on someone next time don't do that and
it's just like I don't want to be that
guy who's getting on someone but they
shouldn't just be like why is he
entitled exactly handicap placard this
seems like a no-win argument for me like
he was like a [ __ ] douche bag or
anything but it's just like my yeah I
just got defensive in the sense of just
like leave me alone dude like I have
cancer like I fought for this too you
know what I mean like I may have I may
have not fought for people's freedom but
I fought for my life you know to get one
of the things on our bucket list is to
get a hundred percent achievements and
colleges which we've never been able to
do but applause are you
we have wheel we've lost our accounts so
yeah we were
someone who knew someone at Activision
and she was like why did you guys get
bass as a trigger are we gonna get
banned we just forgot our user info you
can't recover you use their info anyway
anyone watching a goddamn Activision
help these guys box 360 yeah we are also
planning on doing a 24 hour livestream
we had one scheduled but chemo probs
yeah this girl basically gatekeeping him
from us connecting to Activision to like
promote this stream because she was a
survivor of cancer and she said she
survived it so it's not a real problem
for Chris that person doesn't exist did
you see her cancer card laminated I feel
like nobody survived cancer would ever
say that to anybody I I just know I've
had cancer survivors who have come and
said we're rooting for you you know it's
very difficult I've gone through this
it's hard to find a bone marrow donor
had plenty of that
it's the rarity to find I've gone
through cancer you're not dealing with
[ __ ] suck it up and it's just like
somebody who's been through cancer would
say that it breaks my heart that's true
yeah and for me like we were just
helping out a kid who unfortunately died
in the twenty-eighth he passed away the
other 28 and we asked him what is
something on your bucket list and we
documented his kind of his story he was
first diagnosed before he turned 1 and
what and he beat leukemia donor brain
condition and then yeah he passed about
a week ago it was he when he passed he
was 17 but we like I was saying like -
compared to him I'm a punk [ __ ] like I
I'm here you know I got my hair I'm able
to leave the house he was stuck in a
house literally like like you said
leukemia before the age of 1 and then
going through severe brain tumors it's
like is we we filmed his video and then
one of the things he wanted to do was
meet Will Ferrel because he watched
daddy's home through his treatment and
will film yeah I mean I guess we can
know that I can do is watch movies
that's why it's really important he
can't speak like he literally was so far
gone it's just all he has is movies we
haven't really like formally announced
it yet but that's what we're focusing on
now yeah number 119 is to help other
people with cancer so I mean it's not
just me hon I've got a nice well you
guys are definitely doing that with the
bone like you guys are getting so many
people to register your you're gonna
save life like no matter what happened
eyes are gonna save somebody somewheres
life yeah yeah only not to pick races
but I mean literally the Israeli
community okay like a right more like a
lot of those communities it's talked
about is much it's always by diversity
yeah and so the more diverse people that
you have literally the best so it
Americans the more oriental the more
Latino everything the more it'll save so
when you match with a black dude or
technically I mean like it would be like
it would be like a point zero zero zero
one percent because you know like
genetics are just like a roll of the
dice and you don't know right like
that's the crazy part
it could even be yeah so like I
mentioned kind of losing our jobs and
stuff clay who's been we're helping out
a lot behind the scenes he's we actually
he got married two weeks ago and they're
already talking about divorce because
they have no money but that's a
different story
we
we're making our job our job now is to
help in April 12th we'll be flying in a
girl named Lexi she's in Ohio she's
going through some cancer too one of the
things turns out it's illegal to touch a
cheetah that was one of the things on
her bucket list was to meet a cheetah
and it's a federal crime to touch it
she'll touch the cheetah yeah so she
reaches her hand out we're gonna have to
tackle her but don't touch a cheetah
don't touch a cheetah that should be the
name of this vodka what what has been
throughout all the experiences you guys
have done you've done you've met a lot
of people well it's been like the most
special or fulfilling thing from your
list or not that you guys have done so
far I promise I'm not just saying this
because I'm here you tubers being able
to end like I was saying earlier like
you guys are the media like I don't
watch TV like I have cable and I pay for
cable but I don't use it i watch youtube
for everything news entertainment you
know what I mean just stuff like that
like it's just literally you got two of
them right here the news and the
entertainment and stuff and it's just
like you guys are my outlet so being
able to meet you you know demolition
ranch Achievement Hunter all that stuff
is it's like like I'm very serious you
guys are the ones who take me away from
dealing with cancer problems and it's
more just like Thank You Man one thing
that I know is gonna trigger both of us
that the the last picture of Josh before
he passed he was wearing one of our
shirts sorry to cut you off Dan said we
crashed the registry site good hey you
guys are darks yeah we like to call it
the hug of death in this case maybe
death isn't the best well I wonder if
they could take down our web site - yeah
our web site has the the same like our
own thing to get through be the match
you know just yeah we have an affiliate
link because they they like to keep us
updated with how many lives you've saved
basically well everyone will get a
chance dan what is the link our web site
is one list one life com so you guys can
apparently can sign up there but this
everyone will have a chance to yeah
we're gonna post
you too sure yeah sorry to cut you off
okay hey that was kind of cool I'm
probably getting a text from the
registry right now what did you guys
just do that was the craziest thing it's
like we just got done right we were
filming like we just got done filming
like not the homeless I think the video
after that and we just get a call we're
just sitting in the car and it's just
some random number and they're like hey
this is B The Match registry and we've
seen that you guys have started making
like hundreds of people donate so spike
and they call this out because they
realize we are going to partner with you
guys the previous record was two
thousand eight hundred I believe and
we're not technically official yet but
we broke three thousand it's like that's
a big number obviously but when you
really kind of look at it that is insane
because at least one person yeah so I
mean to be doing something compared to
just sitting in a classroom or just
working and stuff cuz I know it's just
definitely way more rewarding I would
say than most things
I mean construction was rewarding you
get to see I was an electrician I mean
like you got to see a house turn on from
nothing and it's just like that's cool
this way beats it out because yeah I've
had a a one-armed kid reach out to me
then he does hunting fishing all kinds
of this stuff and he was telling me that
I'm an inspiration I'm like no no no no
shut up you're doing all this stuff
one-handed dude I was like if I lost a
finger I'd be bitching up a storm you're
doing this [ __ ] one [ __ ] handed hell
no you're the inspiration dude like no
and it's just crazy all those people
reaching out and like trying to tell me
I'm an inspiration when there's people
who are living with way worse things I
mean I people say oh you know cancer so
bad but it's like I'm here I get to move
out of that leave the house and I get
all my limbs and everything right now so
I mean there's definitely that was a
good radio experiencing a day as a blind
person that was one of the things on the
bucket list that I think that was one my
favorite yes got a lot of surprised all
the good comments yeah see like a wave
of just troll
just like I just were always expecting
it I love it I think like there's gotta
be some content it's like we're trying
to save my friend's life and then they
make fun of my hair is the cancer cause
Rose just from all around just on Dylan
and me is just they're good they're
really good
so you and talking with you and email
mm-hmm you had brought up a roast me
thread yes you were a big hit on aren't
reddit roast me below you not as row
stable as me but so you wanted to make a
video initially where we go over this
and I looked at I'm like dude this is so
[ __ ] up it's so twisted oh that's good
I would look at it I know you guys want
to and it's fun I'll pull it out but I
want you guys to know I didn't do this I
didn't write these I didn't want to do
this I was saying the disappointing
stuff about some of the Rose Mia's
people put up nice stuff afterwards like
oh they're like oh you know I can't wait
till you die and I see you in your grave
or something and then they're just like
I'm so sorry I don't mean it I'm sorry
that you have cancer I hope you have a
great life and it's like this roast me
like this isn't like I don't get one
point Chris threatened to have sex with
someone's uncle because they weren't
being me oh you know someone was just
like no they were just like oh yeah you
know it's gonna die too bad you're gonna
die a virgin I'm just like don't worry
your uncle already got that covered all
right are you guys ready for this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know all right so every once in
a while cancer gets it right hell yeah
well you responding amen brother yeah
yeah I mean I gives you perspective hi
everyone the kid the kid from Pixar's Up
grew up and got cancer yeah I need to
cosplay the kid from up I need to do
like a good Russell cosplay I'm chubby I
look like it I'll be a good Russell I do
feel like all these comments generally
from
from and this our have a cut like they
mean well we're all be skinny you know
that's that's a pro at least they're
skinny yeah that's pretty brutal I'm
looking for skinny that'd be great
you're asking your dying in your ass for
shitty mean lunch if I were you I'd have
wished for a girlfriend
you like my response I tried with the
people at red at Campbell this is to
mushroom you couldn't be more than the
embodiment of whatever reddit user looks
like alright somebody like the really
nasty one sorry I keep laughing before
you read them and then just like this is
the last one I didn't know cancer could
spread outside the body yeah his
response is my favorite part
yeah it's pretty bad please the gilding
mayor i'm literally i know they said
that it says it's gonna like I was like
you know just in case I die can I like
is there any way I can give reddit gold
to some people I have like a lifetime
supply now like I won't have to see ads
for like a year and like no exception
yeah the moderator that admin admin yeah
he was uh he has an account where he
just can give unlimited gold and
everything he's like yeah look and just
builds my post I'm just like but you
can't give it to other people you know
why would I do that
bro that's like tax fraud yeah we're
calling you out reddit also as I kind of
wrap this up and talk about the
different ways that people can support
you guys I understand that you recently
turned 21 years old yes yes so I wanted
to celebrate with a little something
special with some rapper beverages
because we're all pretty swagged out
here can Dan can you bring in the swag
juice brought some Hennessy like what is
swag it's my
audience for method jackass surrealism
for a moment
oh the jackass 3 the Preston sweat suit
cocktail that I never like I'm never a
weak stomach person like I take chemo
and stuff but like that episode I was
just just go just remember just think
it's he gets on a bike like a word like
plastic wrap so it Crippin yeah for like
into a glass damn what I got here Don
Perry on I don't I think I got the grape
juice for doing oh if it's a good
vintage for Christopher approves can you
open it on that side guys so while we're
cracking up in these boxes as I said if
when I use sons of [ __ ] out there
matches I will give you $5,000 and a
[ __ ]
the bucket list item you've heard of the
Hope Diamond it's like that
okay it's priceless you just mash it do
you do anything like Sayaka technique I
swirl out there all right the websites
Doc's does they don't and if you don't
know
in the dick slap
the lake is on the screen the link is in
the description join dot be the match
dork slash my best friend guys all you
do it's free if you're between the age
of 18 to 44 free cuz if you're old let's
be real we don't want your [ __ ] it's
just less ya get older your cells adapt
to your body and they know like this is
you and so when you try and take it out
and put it in someone's else yourselves
like no this is not me yeah so the older
you are the more your cells really
acquaint to you so you can you can't
still do it bucks and saving someone's
life I would say is priceless yeah 18:44
it's free they send you out a little cat
all you do is swab the side of your
mouth you send it I'm gonna do it I was
hoping to get it in time for this we did
it but it just takes like five days and
when you match they just stick you they
stick you a little bit and you save a
life do it out of curiosity how many
people are watching we might have just
topped our own record well right now
live there's rings 8,000 watching live
just topped our own world record will
get a lot it will get more views when we
post on you right so yeah we'll see but
we got it we got to assume that most of
them have already done it because it's
been like out there you can't just
assume every large one of you guys get
on that web calling be the match right
now let them know we doubled we're
hoping I feel like that'd be kind of a
boring picture drunk so guys and if you
want to help support them on their
mission to fulfill the rest of the items
on their bucket list or just to get out
and shake their dicks and do their thing
the link to their patreon is also in the
description on the screen patreon.com
slash my best friends list i recently
supported and i recommend you guys to as
well to be here honestly like is is a
dream item and i it's always weird like
meeting like these big youtubers that's
like a borderline of like being a big
fan and trying to be normal because i
understand people can get creepy fast
I've seen your guys's stuff like people
just showing up at your house like what
the [ __ ] is that like we just had
someone show up at his house the other
day and like wreaked out it wasn't even
for us it was for his dad's company but
oh yeah but we were just strolling we
don't have fans they all play me for the
cancer day I can't even imagine you guys
having to deal with that like Pete
alright I'm antisocial I may not seem
like it I just want to sit in my house I
don't want to deal with anyone I just
wanna play games and just to have people
first of all let's Cheers happy birthday
cheers to you
cheers see you my dude happy 21st
birthday very happy to be here with you
what do you think all right it's good I
don't get the hype I mean it's like a
thing you know it's $150 bottle of
champagne that was $150 yeah that's what
I thought
you lasted longer than it
I meant 2009 the cancer that was a
cancer joke to me it's just like it's
like weird Sanpellegrino I'm like you
ever had that yeah by the way I learned
my lesson you drink at the bottom of the
show like don't drink at the beginning
of the show when you get him drunk he's
missing some sloppy [ __ ] yeah it's gonna
be great
I was I was like sorry just had like
thinking like a quarter of a beer before
here just cuz he's like dude he's right
one beer like when I took my first beer
[ __ ] me up like that's enough you can
talk you're 21 it's gonna say this is
totally my soda drinking he was 151
that's my favorite it better
it better be liquid lava I'm gonna get
drunk I don't do you was sitting here
drinking like seven eight shots you know
I'd rather take three shots and get to
where I would be and not have to take
like eight shots just see like yeah he's
got that conversion ratio down you've
been crunching the numbers but you're
saying I don't know how you feel about
like being like a famous youtuber to me
I still don't really I don't like feel
it I just feel like a normal dude still
like no I would say people just trying
to try to log into my stuff more I feel
like it was actually worse the worst
when I was like a smaller youtuber I
don't know if it's a people feel a
connection but like I I think I talked
about on the podcast last time like I
changed my name to DeFranco initially to
avoid people finding my house because
people started showing up
there are some people that actually they
are willing to sacrifice their life for
Chris that's not a joke they say I will
die and give you my bone marrow and I
have lived an amazing life and Chris
seems like a great person and you know
I've I've lived a great life so I'm
ready to live lay down my life and you
know give him my bone marrow it's like
when you drive I feel just some twisted
dude you're like I can't even use it we
were saying I mean we'll take down bone
marrow donations of any type you want to
just take some out put it in a ziploc
bag send it get someone that was really
confused about what a bone marrow is
litters gonna send you a limb yeah it'll
be fresher if they just send us the bone
you know what we're doing send us the
whole way yeah you guys Rock thank you
that's funny I enjoy watching you guys a
story and you're quorums with YouTube
that's hilarious to watch oh they're
getting Deamonte oh they're totally d
monetize oh it still drives me crazy
just so you guys know my favorite
episode one with all the risque girls
that you know they're just like getting
the egg sandwich just like that's such a
prime example of like the stupidity of
it like you can see they're just make
jokes yeah fun of it and like I don't
think that's our last video I've been
wanting to pitch about this thank you
for bringing it out our last video about
prank invasion got demonetized really we
put so much work and effort into it and
like all the sudden you can't even make
like making fun of something in the eyes
of the classifiers is the same as doing
it yourself so if I'm making fun of
Chris doing kissing pranks on some girl
in a burka and they censor the part
where you lifts her skirt and grabs her
ass and fingers are
as well I apparently it's just as bad as
me going and doing it myself you want to
know the best we don't get monetized we
get Mars is too or we have to so you
talk about death too much yeah because
it's you know scary shield your eyes I
refuse to believe that advertisers
really care like every time I talk to
you do but not a lot but like if if our
if ads showed up on your guys's videos
would would brands give a [ __ ] no I
don't think so
well that's problem is they're just
they're classifying you guys talking
about something like that to like a
bombing the same day it's the same sauce
is just a serious topic that shouldn't
be talked about one thing a lot of
people ask they're just wanna point out
you can't see our bucket lists a lot of
people want to see it we do it online
yeah yep what does the asterisk means it
means it's a work in progress base I'm
good I don't have a drink so I'm just
like oh yeah I feel great you guys feel
great sorry bro
don't judge me once we start getting a
little drunk I was like I just I'm
looking forward to after we're done and
everyone knows we've got some we tried
to order Papa John's which I thought
that'd be a suiting thing to do but
guess what Papa doesn't deliver to the
zip code so guess who I called the new
official sponsor the NFL and my life
Pizza
[Music]
it's a sponsorship sorry I know I blow a
lot of smoke up of people's ass here but
when it comes to be acted like how when
I was told I have cancer what no
monetization for you recently it's not
5050 anymore but it's still enough to be
just like why did you the thing but I
don't even try and talk about it like
it's kind of the same as a for a lot of
youtubers I say there's like a certain
algorithm to when you can say that
you're depressed it's like one one time
one depending on your output for people
like yeah yeah the thing that bothers me
is not that it happens it's like
whenever it happens I'm like why like I
tried my best to make this video
acceptable it's so complicated from
there so leave it to me the chemo and
although I can't accept bone marrow I'm
gonna reopen my patreon we've got some
pizza waiting for us guys thank you so
much for watching I please hope that you
will join the registry link is in the
screen some description let's do this
y'all thank you so much and yeah
subscribe wait what's the one less one
life is that all of our self is one one
less one life you know ever you're
looking for them there they are
what triggered all right let's plate
some pizza all right guys thank you so
much for watching thanks guys
remember on Wednesday we are going to be
live with post Malone at our first live
show super live layers of live live live
and then Friday Bob Saget so I hope you
will join us for the rest of the week
okay love you guys all right see you
then Tata